there's been a
chess controversy about cheating and so
on that you've covered people should
subscribe to your channel your your
hilarious entertaining brilliant and
it's just uh fun to learn from you
do you think as we stand now Hans ever
cheated in over the board chest what as
things stand
now at the beginning of October yeah
it's that's a very tough question for a
couple of reasons I think first of all
when people refer to evidence in regards
to whether Han street over the board
there is not I don't think there ever
will be quote-unquote hard evidence the
only thing that would ever constitute
that is if he's caught in the act
literally he's caught like using a phone
with an earpiece whatever it might be
that is the only way that there would
ever be hard evidence so as it stands
right now there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence how much of it
is legitimate or not remains to be seen
I know people have questioned the
statistics some people think it's very
convincing some people think it's
complete nonsense
I think I think that right now I'm I'm
very undecided uh but I I do feel that
within the next like three to six months
assuming Hans is able to play over the
board and more tournaments the stats
will make it very clear one way or the
other based on results whether it's
legitimate or not I think I think for me
I would say that regardless of whether
whether you whether like I believe you
cheated or not he is playing at probably
a 20 he's probably at least 2 650 no
matter what regardless of whether he's
cheating or not he's already at that
level which is very very high so I think
the stats will will bear it out in the
next probably I say I said three to six
months probably I would say next six to
12 months
um whether something happened but
I I really don't know do you find
compelling or interesting uh the kind of
analysis where you compare the
correlation between engines and humans
to to try to determine if cheating was
done in part so initially I thought that
that was actually quite legitimate but
as I as I found out much more recently
anybody can basically upload this data
so that whole Theory while it seemed
very convincing at the time it simply
isn't isn't any statistical
um evidence in my opinion now but there
there are games from some of those
tournaments that definitely considering
where his rating was look very
suspicious in 2020 I would say
um again that's not the role like myself
to decide or chess.com that's obviously
going to be up to fide whether they
think that's compelling evidence or not
um I think for me
what I would say from an intuitive
standpoint is that I've been in this
world for a very very long time I've
I've seen mostly Juniors as they've
risen through the ranks Magnus and many
others
um and there's always been something
about them that has stood out to me
that's been like a brilliant game
they've played against someone who's
much higher rated I've just seen it from
all the all those players I never really
saw that with Hans Neiman so it's very
difficult for me to sort of with my own
twice being in this Chess World so long
see things a certain way and then like
something that's never happened before
is happening but at the end of the day
it is still possible it is completely
possible that Hans something clicked at
a certain age and he started improving
in spite of the fact that you know the
statistics look weird in terms of his
rating Improvement so I don't know I I
sort of I think that in six to 12 months
I'll probably be able to say one way or
the other with very certain confidence
like you know whether whether it should
be there or not speaking of Statistics
uh I should ask I'm not sure about this
are you a data scientist right that's a
good one no of course I'm not you know
but it's that's the thing you see you
see all these stats are thrown out there
and you you try to try to understand
what's being said
um but it's it's also very scary because
when you see these things that look very
legitimate and then they're they're
disproven or people say like you're
cherry picking like the dates and all
these other things it almost feels like
you can come to any conclusion that you
want to yeah and that's why I think this
is such a serious issue for the world of
Chess because
going forward if we don't take it
seriously now I think at some point
there is the potential for a much much
larger Scandal do you agree that like
with Magnus I think said that it is an
existential threat to chess like this is
a very serious problem that's only going
to get bigger because it's you're
basically
uh from a spectator perspective from a
competitor perspective or not sure that
you can trust any of the results
that's for sure true when I think back
to the last like five to ten years there
are plenty of top level tournaments that
I played in where there was no security
at all yeah um you just you just go into
the auditorium and play your games and
that was that so I do think it's a big
issue I think it has been a big issue
but the reason it's only coming to light
now is because it features a very strong
Junior player who's very close to the
world's Elite there have been many
achieving scandals before uh there was
this French player Sebastian Fowler
there was this player Igor's Rouses from
Latvia
um there was this uh I think it's from
Belarus or maybe I have that wrong maybe
it's Bulgaria borislav Ivanov as well
those are three big cheating scandals
but they were not at the absolute top
levels of Chess which I think is why
um it never became the huge news story
that this is or it wasn't viewed in the
same kind of ways why I think organizers
were perhaps a little bit too LAX in
terms of security
so you said
2650 is it possible
that Hans is in fact a kind of Bobby
Fischer level of genius and he's capable
at times of Genius at the chessboard oh
absolutely a hundred percent that that
is absolutely possible I think that's
why I think for everybody in the
situation we want to see what happens in
the next six to 12 months because I
think it will be very clear also it's
very interesting to me because there are
other stats from that 72-page report
that chess.com compiled which in essence
says certain other Junior players
basically have peaked that they're not
likely to improve further so it's also
going to be very interesting when you
look at those like I think it was like
50 pages of graphs because there are
graphs that say like some of the other
Junior players are done so when we look
forward like in a year or two if those
players don't improve it will also say
something about their methods as well
that they've used to sort of compile
this data
yeah I wonder what those Junior players
do if they look at that data so there's
a point where you should look at
yourself like practically
like what what is the actual empirical
data over the past year of how much I've
improved at a particular thing like it's
one thing to kind of tell yourself that
these are the ways I need to improve and
it's another to actually look at the
data and face the reality of it right I
I think also that could have a
psychological effect that is the other
thing that makes the whole Han situation
so tough because if you think that he's
cheated or you're unsure about what's
going on that is another psychological
Factor whenever you play against it in
his favor or against a favor definitely
in his favor because for example if I go
online and play against the computer
let's just say I go play against sawfish
tomorrow I'm gonna play a very certain
type of opening strategy try to keep the
board closed and maybe hope to get lucky
now computers have gotten so good that
generally even that doesn't I don't even
have a chance even with such strategies
but you play differently than you
normally would and so if you're playing
a game against him and there's a move
that looks really weird
um it doesn't seem logical at all that
can also start to affect you where you
immediately make a mistake or you start
questioning yourself you start thinking
well what's going on here is there
something
um something Unbecoming like you start
worrying about what is happening and so
it definitely is uh it is it's a very
tough situation
do you agree with magnus's decision to
Forfeit the match his most recent match
with Hans uh tough question I I don't
in my heart of hearts I feel like there
had to be a better way to handle it than
what Magnus did on the other hand sort
of being in this world of top Grand
Masters having heard these rumors for
two years I think that the fact that it
was blown off and it wasn't treated
seriously I'm not sure if there was a
better option so my heart of hearts I
feel like there had to be a better way
to handle it but in practicality or like
in the Practical world
I don't I think he might have made the
only decision where it became a big
issue
yeah I mean I guess I would have loved
to see just where 100 it's certain that
there's no cheating involved that they
play a bunch of games
yeah I think there was actually an
article that was released today by uh
Ken rogoff who is a grand master at
chess where he wrote this article in the
Boston Globe and he essentially said
that like have Hans and Magnus play a
match and see what his score is because
statistically if it's above a certain
percentage that means he's legitimate
because of course you have security
um if it's below that might mean that
probably means that he's not at the
level
um that he's at so I don't know if
that's a real way to settle it
necessarily
um because also for Magnus to ask him to
play against someone who's cheated I
think for him he just he would never
entertain the idea because it's like why
am I going to play against someone who
cheated so yeah I don't I don't know
it's very tough and you know one one
other thing I would say on the topic
that's really important to note is this
sort of came from from left field for
most people who are in the general
public are very casual chess players but
this is not something that wasn't known
wasn't even on the radar I I think this
has not been said before but there's
there's one of these things where they
talk about how Hans has uh he's he
played better during a period of time
when games are broadcast versus not
broadcast I actually heard this rumor
two years ago during during one of the
terms he's playing specifically so that
is the thing is that this has been out
there for a very long time and so it's
it's hard because you do believe that
Magus could have handled it better but
if it was two years of these rumors and
nothing was done about it I don't know
and for people who don't understand when
it's broadcast it's easier to cheat
because you can have
it removes one of the challenges of
cheating which is the one-way
communication from the board to the
engine here the engine can just watch
the broadcast and then all you have to
do is then signals right back uh I mean
that's really I've woken up to this fact
actually uh programmed so setting all
the silly sex toys aside
um I have uh
I have a bunch of these devices so like
of this um is the size of a coin and it
has a high resolution vibration that you
can send so you can just have this in
your pocket it's basically what your
your smartphone has ability to uh
vibrate you can do programmatic
communication through anything Bluetooth
is the easiest so like this made me
wonder like
wait a minute how often does this happen
like at every level of play and you said
this only became a huge concern
for uh at the highest level of play but
then how much cheating is going on at
like the the middle level of play
especially when more money is involved
so in the Game of Poker when like it's
it really
um it really made me think like the
future will have devices like this much
easier to like you will engineer smaller
smaller and smaller devices that have
onboard compute
that like
like this is the future I mean I I just
it makes me um I think probably with all
kinds of cyber security that means the
defense will just have to get started to
get better even with chess it seems like
the security is very clumsy just looking
the scanning of the recent tournament
one thing you'll see is there a lot of
people are talking about whether Hans
has cheated or not the one thing that
almost nobody is doing is actually like
trying to show how it can be done yeah
everyone's basically avoiding that I
think the single biggest reason for that
is simply because it can be done very
easily at like a weekend term if you
play a weekend tournament where the top
prize is a hundred dollars and the
players are maybe Master Level somebody
could already do this because even in St
Louis now where they have the security
my understanding is the one the um the
non-linear Junction device they bought
costs about eleven thousand dollars
um and organizers if you if you have a
weekend tournament at the at the local
Club you don't have eleven thousand
dollars to spend on such a device and so
that is why a lot of people have been
talking about it but I think it is very
very serious and it's that's why it is
good even if you know aside from Hans
even it is a very important question or
debate to be having at the present
moment well I think I think it's good to
talk about it right to make it so that
the defenses will really step up I think
you could do pretty cheap like the
security pretty cheaply uh yeah but you
have to you take it seriously right
right of course uh and again we'll we'll
see what happens I think that's gonna
end up being on feed it more than anyone
else to try and do that I I don't think
asking the organizers to do it I mean I
feel like fide they are the governing
body it will be on them at the end of
the day to figure it out but it's uh
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens in the next couple of months